as the December 6 runoff for the Georgia
Senate election gets closer and closer
one candidate Rafael Warnock is making
more and more sense the other candidate
Herschel Walker is increasingly unable
to speak we're going to look at clips of
both options that Georgia voters have on
December 6. remember that if you vote in
Georgia the Senate races are not over we
know Democrats will control the Senate
but will it be 50 50 or 5149 that's
going to come down to a runoff election
in Georgia the reason there is a runoff
is that Georgia has something called the
50 rule
the 50 rule states that if not If no
candidate in a regular election gets to
fifty percent of the vote the top two
vote Getters will have a runoff and
indeed although Raphael Warnock got more
votes than Herschel Walker neither can
that it got to 50 because of a third
party candidate and so there is going to
be a runoff on December 6th Herschel
Walker in a completely deranged weekend
saying things that don't make any sense
about anything here he is in one clip
blaming Rafael Warnock for A disruption
to his speech that was caused by an
ambulance driving by listen to this
I'm that Warrior for God and he sent
down here to get that man out of office
I'm that Warrior for God that he sent
down here because I don't dance and sing
for nobody I never have and never will
because I remember in my office lineman
used to tell me there's a her should
follow me I'll take you to the promise
Lane so I'm gonna tell all you vote for
me we all get to the promised land
because we're not gonna get there by one
I want all of us to get together because
that's what we are with God's people and
we got to get that together we're going
to work this thing out together you guys
following this do it because in the
Bible I read it said a house the body
cannot stand I don't know what Bible
Senator Warner is reading but it's not
the Bible I've been reading because he
don't seem to be doing the right thing
by him that must be Senator we're not
doing this right here trying to cancel
me out but he can't cancel me out cause
I'm the man of God God loved me and I
can tell you that right now he loves me
and I'ma tell you this right here
because it's getting cold outside but
cold weather only make us better yeah uh
really just commenting on everything
from uh police responses to Godliness
and and weather and just everything at
another event uh the trend we saw was
that Walker's attacks on Warnock became
not only increasingly incoherent but
also sort of strange in this word salad
Walker tosses up the idea that Warnock
is not God's people but I started
watching television and I Came Upon A
Man by the name of Raphael wanna well
this was so funny and I'm gonna get into
it no no don't boom he's he's uh one
fall short and glory god let's just
think about it and he uh he is all
watching him in Chester the other day I
heard him preaching in his church about
me he said some of the things I said is
venomous and vile you know he said that
you know when you talk about him you're
talking about Jesus and you're talking
about Dr Luther King and this was so
funny about it he is correct when you
talk about God's people you sometimes
talk about Jesus but he's not God's
people because he's not doing it right
by what God is telling him to do right
crystal clear folks this is an election
that is less about any particular issue
and more about values
consistency and who do we want
representing Us in the Senate big
picture and that's what I'm going to
come back to after we we look at the uh
Raphael Warnock clips now just one more
of Herschel Walker blaming Warnock for
something related to Archie Bunker not
being on TV anymore I mean is it these
are it's almost like a random word
generator he is a man coughing like has
he read the Bible I read because it
talks about forgiveness they said don't
look at this spec in your brothers I
look at the point in your own eye you
got to ask for forgiveness and he never
asked for forgiveness and moved on he's
still talking about the past we don't
want to live in the past y'all can I
tell you this here aren't you Barker
when he would be on the air today would
it now and and I tell you what I used to
love Archer bunker did you not like
Archer Parker Kobe causing Senator work
now it wouldn't be on air because he's
still living in the past I don't know
what he's talking about
it wouldn't be on Archie Bunker went off
the air in 1983 and the guy who played
Archie Bunker died more than 20 years
ago
it's just this this is not about which
candidate's tax policy do we prefer
okay this is absurd now on the other
side of this we have a very good
candidate an uncontroversially good
candidate here is a viral ad that
Raphael Warnock put out in an extremely
sophisticated way equating Herschel
Walker's policies to dog poop is it just
me or does it feel like we've been here
before the whole country's finished
voting and only us left you think
Herschel Walker would want to explain
what he'd do in the Senate if he
actually wants to represent Georgia
instead he repeats the same lies trying
to distract from what we all know is
true about him but I think Georges will
see his ass for what they are
don't you
I'm Rafael Warnock yep so anyway he
dumps dog poop into a trash can when he
says I think people will see his lies
for what they are and then here is
Raphael Warnock making sure people
understand this from just a few days ago
there is going to be a runoff there is
another election coming well Georgia
here's the deal it's now clear our race
is going to a runoff on November 8th the
people of Georgia showed up you showed
out while we received more votes than my
opponent because we came up just shy of
50 of the vote we're going to a runoff
so I'm going to need all of you every
single one of you to go and vote one
more time on or before
December 6th this runoff is about who is
ready to represent you who will actually
work for Georgia it's about who will
stand up and fight for a better tomorrow
for all of our children early voting
runs November 28th through December 2nd
and runoff election day is December 6th
now nobody believes a preacher when he
says in closing but I'll close with this
go vote your vote is your voice your
voice is your human dignity and Georgia
I need you to raise your voices again
louder than ever are you ready because
I'm ready to keep working for Georgia
it's the honor of my life let's do this
thing
one more time all right so there are no
shortage there is no shortage of
opportunities to get involved you can of
course donate and many of you wrote to
me and said you have donated you can
phone bank I believe that a Cuban
American streamer Stephen Kenneth
Destiny Bonnell the second is going to
be leading a coalition of uh canvassing
down in Georgia I don't have the details
in front of me but I believe it will be
the weekend of uh you know I don't I
think it's the first couple days of
December but we can get that information
we have to get involved with this one if
Warnock wins
you knock out the power of mansion slash
Cinema like yes there's still two of
them you need one of them but you can
lose one of them and still have 50. and
that is of critical importance and we
are going to follow this one this is the
race at this point in time if you have a
friend a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift of reforest station to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 percent off and your plot
of land will be right next to mine you
can see it on a map go to
establishedtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for an extra 10 off on top
of their Black Friday deal the link is
down below